espino first time ever against the
rockies none of their starting lineup
guys have ever faced him before and
here's a one-two
swing and a miss on a big slider by
paulo his 84th strikeout as he works his
98th inning of the year 1-2
breaking ball hit towards center field
it'll drop for a base hit brendan
rodgers makes it a six-game hitting
streak a one-out man aboard for the
rockies
swing and a miss
after those 70-something curveballs the
heater played a lot faster than 89. i
feel pretty straight away for story we
saw his opposite field ability yesterday
and he can't get to that paulo espino
three swinging first inning strikeouts
john gray's on the mat 27 start for john
the stuff of late has been good
shallow center field and making a
sliding catch and a beauty
to start the afternoon as garrett
hampson speed speed speed that's why you
need to have it in the outfield
particularly center field well he makes
up for he took one drop step back and
then has to take his direct line to it
he might be fighting the sun as well
line drive right center escobar has
another base in
charlie blackman over to cut it and now
he's 12 for his last 34
over seven games plus one a b two on two
out for yadiel hernandez they'll set up
in
and that ball was way inside and yadiel
just put the gnats on top
escobar speeding home bell to third
yacht e l and it's one nothing
washington
[Applause]
and there's a strike out of key boom in
the inning john gray ends up giving up a
run there were two hits and a walk
sandwiched in there so we go to the
second the nationals leading one to
nothing on this sunday afternoon another
3-2 count here
swing and a miss there is something
disappearing about that fastball this
afternoon it's invisible four swinging
strikeouts
there's a pitch strike three called at
the knees to end the second john gray
gets his second strikeout
spino at 50 pitches now
and follows spino has five strikeouts
and john's ready
the pitch
cold strike three at the knees
beautiful fastball by john gray and that
strikeout number three thomas shaking
his head as he goes back to the dugout
that's a great slider another strikeout
two in a row four all together one base
20 of his last 21 33 out of 36. at the
end of yesterday's game his unbased
percentage reached 460.
soto
right center
c
u
way later
that almost made it to the concourse at
the back of the first level
454. it's a daily privilege to watch
juan soto play baseball
pulled on the ground and it hops past
crone
josh bell makes the turn heads for third
blackman up firing he is safe
so runners at the corners with two outs
and he got kibum again on a slider in
the inning juan soto hit a ball
454 feet two nothing nationals
but he hasn't walked anybody but he
struck out six and again rogers may be
looking secondary and he got the express
he's sneaking the fastball by the
rockies right now
this ball's well hit the center field
going back is thomas and it's off the
wall
and charlie in a second with a double so
that snaps a run of nine straight
retired by espino
breaking ball
oh escobar grabs it blackman thought it
was going over the infield
and then that's going to break on a 6-4
line drive double play left fielder sam
hilyard next 2-2
sway and a miss
i mean that said 88 did you see that
swing and we've been seeing those swings
all day from rocky's players i mean it's
playing way up from 88. watch a swing
everyone's been late on upper 80s low
90s all day the invisible fastball from
palo espino has been working you're
still just the bloop and a blast away or
in this case a walk and a blast from
trevor story
and this one is down the left field line
charlie
is going to stop
smartly at second the ball was only
about a 80-foot throw
from left field there's two outs this
should be a decent ovation i mean you
can't do any better than paulo espino
did today let's walk him off austin both
last appearance tuesday night where the
nets beat the marlins 8-2 on 17 pitches
12 strikes
3-2 ball four and now they're loaded up
for ryan mcmahon here's the rockies
opportunity albeit with two outs
pretty well hit to left yaddiel back
he's got it exhale rocky strand three in
the net still lead to
nothing
with the net struggling mightily at the
back end of the bullpen
rainey up relatively early and josh
bell's on for the third time today stay
hot josh
he has two hits in the series and he's
been on base five times adio hernandez a
flare to right center for an rbi in the
first
that ball hit hard to right diving and
it's in front of charlie blackman who
knocks it down yaddio hernandez on the
button three times and he's two for
three lucas gilbreth to the mound here
trying to get the final out in the
bottom of the sixth inning runners at
first and third
that is well placed
josh bell home
rounding second getting back ruiz high
throw picked up by mcmahon you don't
have to hit him hard if you put it in
play and then answer on top three
nothing louie louie
and a blown up bat
and
the throw to first is just in time to
get adams in the inning there was a base
hit by bell and he would eventually come
around on a base hit by garcia so now
the rockies trailed three nothing going
into the seven two apps that'll bring up
blackman third man out of the bullpen
thompson's pitch is
hit in the air to left center field
coming in
thomas and the left fielder hernandez
who couldn't grab it and blackman ends
up at second
and this is slowly hit trevor with the
great wheels at key boom smartly didn't
throw it that's a different guy running
and it's not a knock at all on brandon
rogers rogers an average runner story's
anything but so now it's first and third
and the tying runs gonna come up in cj
crone
got him that's what you can do when you
get ahead the slider unreachable good
sequence by machado and now can kyle
finnegan finish things off
swing and a miss on
split action upstairs for the first down
now your ground ball away from shaking
hands
in the o2 escobar
will do it himself
game over
so great play by ocd's escobar and put
the curly w in the books
big win they needed that
you